luke und meine damen und herren es ist
mal wieder soweit heute spielen wir
wieder zusammen
falls nicht genau wisst was movistar
planet ist wo wart ihr in den letzten
wochen auf einem kanal wir werden uns
mal wieder direkt den chat rein bewegen
und erst mal schauen was bei den leuten
so abgeht er mich würde sagen wir gehen
ins einkaufszentrum ist wichtig meiner
ansicht nach so ein bisschen interaktion
mit den leuten direkt so wäre kann wenn
ich ein kerl wäre also die userin namens
little hier wäre gerne ein mann ihr
status ist ja die marke jan behrendt ich
bin ein mann lohnt weil 1 1
[Musik]
die zwei wie geht's dir also der liste
geht es um die unterhaltung damals ein
bisschen weiter voranzubringen schreibe
ich jetzt einfach mal max die idee
fanden aber muss meine shisha rauchen
bin ich denn hier gelandet also ich
würde sagen wir verlassen wir das
einkaufszentrum und gehen in london
droht ich fand ja man merkt dass ich
eine woche nicht online waren leider
ordnung als wenn mein outfit nicht dafür
geeignet ist also ich muss mir hier im
klamotten shop jetzigen fans die
gegenstand kaufen ich glaube ich
entscheide mich für diese sonnenbrille
also die sonnenbrille habe ich am start
das heißt ich ticke jetzt mal auf lohn
von matic an und es ist es her bin ich
im waschsalon mit hänger die einzige
person wir geben auf das profil von ihr
sie ist auf jeden fall auch wfp alle
sagen alles wird gut doch aus dem alles
wird gut wir tropfendes blut du sprichst
mir aus der seele war otto metern hat
einen status weil er hat mich berührt es
ist in meinen augen einfach mega wichtig
dass wenn andere leute ihnen etwas
wichtiges in ihrem start zu stehen haben
dass man dafür dann auch tops verteilt
ich habe zum beispiel bei mir drin
stehen ich bin der uel und bei 4.000
wurde um widerstand ist zwecklos
ich hab noch mal nach und humana bist du
hier
dann kommt hier die black 3 4 6
das macht ein neues youtube-video nee
ich züchte hier eilt echsen weißt du ja
sorry aber was ist das für eine blöde
frage also denke ich spiele meiner
freizeit mobistar planet ganzen quatsch
mich hier alle voll in diesem komischen
waschsalon ich habe meine wäsche schon
fertig von daher gehen wir mal wieder in
denen wie ein flop das war da ja letztes
mal so mega geil damals nur wie ein paar
sekunden später ist elefanten asche
wieder das tanzbein schwingen
also wen haben wir denn ihr heute mit
knapp unter anderem coco wanne ist da
die hollister skorpion kündigt sechs mal
schauen was der fünf status hat wünsche
euch allen eine schöne woche
also ich glaube wirklich in die ip
klappt da merkt man halt hey das sind
leute die neben wirklich geld in die
hand für movistar kleine diesen alle
voll höflich mir dein geld
was was für'n was für geld was für geld
willst du was denn hier los wenn ich
einfach einen klub reingehen würde zehn
sekunden da drin bin und da comdirect
mädel an und fragt michael gib mir dein
geld nach was denkst du denn da was soll
ich denn egal du sagst du willst mein
geld für etwas denn vor neid
ok freunde in jeder folge denke ich mir
wir haben echte neuen tiefpunkt erreicht
stinkst echt nach ja und das riecht
immer noch besser als du ja gut ich
würde sagen wir verlassen dann auch mal
den club und gehen zu guter letzt noch
mal leben in den skatepark
das war bisher immer das ende der folge
ich weiß übrigens dass er mir auch ganz
ganz viele von euch immer und in die
kommentare geschrieben bei den letzten
teilen movistar planet ich weiß dass wir
auch ganz ganz viele andere sachen in
diesem spiel noch machen können wie
beispielsweise
daher der appell von mir an euch m
schreibt mir jetzt mal gerne und in die
kommentare was sich in der nächsten
folge movistar kleinen machen soll soll
ich mir vielleicht sogar 94 machen
oder soll ich erst meine freundin finden
oder soll ich mich wieder um style und
ich mir ein haus zu kaufen schreibt ja
auf jeden fall mal gerne und in die
kommentare aber ich begrüße jetzt erst
mal freundlich nett und angemessen die
leute hier im skatepark an die skater
sind dumm wie brot der richtige keine
freude machen
von daher gehe ich jetzt mal direkt er
wieder nett in die unterhaltung je zwei
seid richtig blöde kühl
weshalb nicht mit mir an bilder elefant
[Musik]
eine beleidigung ist wie dein outfit
schlecht sagt der mit einer glatze
das äußerliche von elephant ag in einem
feschen idol schlechthin durch hard von
diffamierungen muss ich mir wirklich
nicht bieten lassen mobistar planet von
daher will ich das heutige video und der
ist jetzt auch beenden wenn euch dieser
fünfte teil movies tabletten gefeiert
dann lasst unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da schreibt mir
gern weil ich jetzt in die kommentare
dinge die ich in der nächsten folge
movistar planet mit elefanten h und mir
luca umsetzen soll dann werde ich die
eventuell in der nächsten folge lacht
vielleicht 6.0 machen die kommt in ca 1
aber online
und falls jetzt nicht verpassen wollt
dann abonniert main kanal einfach unter
dem wie auch abonieren clique nicht
sehen wir das voll viele leute von euch
gar nicht abonnent sind von einem kanal
also ist kostenlos klickt auf aber jetzt
kann der traum
[Musik]
ein